[Music]
i always screw up my recording settings
when i do a live stream and then come
back to this
why would you the settings have to be
different
yeah it's way too quiet
when i do it on online or on live
i wonder why
i have no idea something different with
youtube
well it's probably the program it's
actually the program input
versus okay because now i'm using adobe
audition
so your new video came out how long has
it been since your uh documentary since
the documentary came out i think it came
out in
august
and here's the thing
i was like before
all this before this like phase of my
development as a youtuber
i could pump out a video in three weeks
no problem especially if i'm on camera
the reason i put myself on camera in the
first place
was cut down editing
was yeah so that like there's something
on screen
that i don't have to just make out of
graphics but as you can see this video
was just
end to end graphics and i watched hours
of cnn from the 90s 90s cnn oof so you
don't want to see you don't want to be
on camera anymore
well ideally i wouldn't be
one my favorite comment was
i i love your content but i [ __ ] hate
your ugly millennial face
[Laughter]
very constructive criticism i know i i i
change your face bro
one of your videos i feel like you're a
hijack video like you were wearing like
some like low-cut tank top or whatever
that that i feel like true i was wearing
a v-neck
i dress like that all the time
and then i no okay and here's the thing
about that trick
so many comments for wearing that and
i'm i'm used to that [ __ ] though i've
been called a hipster [ __ ] since i was
17. and that's when the only actual
hipsters were still in brooklyn not even
portland yet but there was no thought
put into that outfit it wasn't trying to
make a statement it was like i was
wearing that shirt already and then the
mic was banging around because it was
like a v-neck
and then the jacket was on the chair in
the room so i put it on and clipped the
mic to it and i wasn't trying to make a
fashion statement at all but i guess i
triggered some people to whom that's
important
anyway if i'm in the video at all it
really is just to save time or because
the content is too abstract to use
footage but that's a really big deal to
some people who [ __ ] know people
probably think that you have like so
you're very like
very hyper conscious of like your
wardrobe choices can you please just
confirm for our patron audience that i
just dressed like that he does it's more
it's more his frame
yeah it's just he's wearing like a funky
colorful like t-shirt right now but
that's just a crew neck it's house it's
how clothes hang on his body right he's
got like the shorter legs and the larger
like torso section and then he's got
like the sort of structure that makes
him look skinny even if he's got a punch
whereas like when i'm feeling skinny and
i stand in front of the mirror there's
still a big shadow underneath like where
my belly meets my crotch and i'm like
[ __ ] i thought i was doing it all right
like i just perpetually look fat no
matter what
even if i'm like done i'm down to 190
i'm i'm 190 is like a good low weight
for me
i feel like you paid way more attention
than i ever have
this is very educational you don't know
what i think about
you don't want to know
it's hard to dress when you have a weird
body type but you've got the good body
type where clothes just hang nicely
everything you wear looks like you
bought it at like hugo boss or something
like that with the long shirts
i have a problem with my like thigh so i
have to buy like athletic fit like pants
because like my thighs are just like too
tight in normal sized pants oh do you
always rip like the crotch of your pants
yeah always if i rip the crotch of every
single pat like i until i discovered
athletic fit which they now sell at like
most of like the gap slash old navy
stores they have like athletic fit as
one of their standard fits and it was
like life changing athletic fit with the
flex oh my god perfect
now i'm living the life big time big
thigh problems yeah i got that too yeah
my the first place to go is always the
crotch area and i i don't buy as many
clothes now because all you see is my
upper body anyway so if i lean too far
forward right now i can see my balls so
i'm not gonna die
no one listening has this he has to see
any of her upper bodies right now this
is where the subscriptions get made and
then we continue into the subject matter
eventually eventually we'll get there
till somebody's talked about their balls
we're not ready to start
did you guys watch pills as new video
uh no not yet it's it's it's on my queue
it's on my youtube queue next to all my
far-right conspiracy videos
anyway
pills your new video so like so it's
taking longer now because you don't want
to be on camera as much anymore
it's not even it's not even that i don't
want to i basically chose that topic so
that i could use footage as the content
instead of myself as the content because
i thought would you say that primarily
the reason you did that was because you
want people to stop commenting on the
clothing that you're wearing oh not at
all
deep insecurity
yes
i was broken by the internet
no that style of documentary is is well
known and adam curtis uses it who's one
of your known inspirations right it's
the it's the voice over style using the
archival footage except in your case you
used like graphics and animation too but
archival footage with a voiceover is
actually it makes you appreciate i i
mean i guess it makes you i you've made
one before appreciate how difficult that
kind of style of documentary is you
think it would be easier because you're
not on camera you have complete control
you can use words and then cut in
whatever images you want but then with
that freedom maybe comes a little bit of
difficulty of shaping a narrative in the
first place when if you have stuff
that's unfolding in front of the camera
right all you have to do is describe it
yeah yeah i just think it makes for
better content it's less less like a
lecture and more like something to
experience i'd say yeah but i really
enjoyed it i mean i feel like you're
really coming into your own with a
certain kind of like stylistic
bent i mean not not
that i would like know how to define it
but i'm noticing like continuity for
sure like with with the archival footage
um and i also felt like maybe that the
narrative style has like
almost
i don't you know
i kept thinking when i was watching it
though about our video or sorry our
episodes which we've done i think a
couple about like critical theory being
a conspiracy theory
yeah like i kind of got that vibe a
little bit from from it like sort of
there's like a suggestive nature to like
okay here's this analysis that brillo
uses
and baudrillard and it's and it's kind
of like you know these controls and now
it's like you know it's not real because
it's just a graphical screen so when
it's not real
uh you know the deaths don't actually
happen and like and then like you know
these military generators were
controlling this narrative
yeah and uh yeah i mean
it's good but i remember thinking to
myself like it's it's also like but
that's i mean that's verilio and
baudrillard maybe like this kind of
the style of doing theory which is which
is like suggestive of like nefarious
intent where there may or may not be it
i guess
um
and i wonder what you thought about that
i prefer it as a style because
like standing up there and teaching why
don't i just do a live stream if i'm
just gonna or just go back to
go back to uh university so
uh really the
idea is actually using the medium for
what i think the medium is best at
and in terms of
conspiratorialness i mean there is we've
talked about those many times
critical theory is conspiratorial so
it's not like
directly conspiratorial this was planned
but in this case it was planned yeah
there was a conspiracy involved the
concrete and sort of provable one i
guess
can you imagine like a roman military
general whose only job is to just go
back and talk about what happened no
they'd be using generals to do whatever
[ __ ] generals do
they wouldn't be just like
pr voices actually one one thought i had
when i was watching it was sort of like
you know the desert storm incident a
desert shield i guess at the time um and
then we got to
you know where these images were being
fed to us in in kind of like a
controlled way but then i feel like one
difference that's interesting uh with
like the iraq war number two
um which you cover a little bit in the
video there's also that like with
wikileaks and and like new like and like
other and like the proliferation of the
internet and like more leaks and more
information like i guess the more that a
medium is being used to control a
message i guess the more opportunity
there is to like also use that same
medium to like expose what's actually
happening right and i think about those
videos that wikileaks released of like
the helicopter and you see the body
parts flying like actual people getting
getting blown up and then it made me
think about zizek
because it made me think about like that
idea of like ideology function where
it's like i vo i know very well but
still i don't care like i don't change
so it's like
part of it seemed like part of the
premise of like the video was like oh
they control the narrative
um they control what we see and what we
don't see so because we're not actually
seeing people it's like pacifies us
um which is premised on maybe this idea
that if we did see it then maybe like
our behavior we would not accept certain
things but then it seems like with the
proliferation of the more and more leaks
in the air and the internet we are
seeing it like we're aware like
everybody's seen those videos with like
body parts and like the guys on the on
the on the radio commenting like got him
should like [ __ ] shot him he's down like
body parts exploring it's like so we see
it happening but yet like nobody's
really like nothing changes i guess
right it's just the same so like whether
we see it or we don't it doesn't seem to
matter and that was that was killing a
reporter the video that you're talking
about exactly yeah yeah well there's a
few but yeah one of them
so and this is something you think about
like maybe like ideology is yeah the
jazz ideologies maybe the other frame
are sort of to think about it like
ideology seems to boil down for zizek to
not to you know putting on the glasses
and seeing things the way they really
are but
but sort of the act of putting on and
taking off the glasses shows you the
difference between things being the way
they are and things understanding that
things are not the way they are that's
kind of the bottom line so even when you
add the sort of truth leak wikileaks
whatever to the debate what it really
just shows people is that things are not
the way they seem not that there's some
deeper underlying truth to what's going
on in front of us
and that's uh i guess that's a sort of
philosophical point that g-jek tries to
make especially in his like um
especially in the perverts guides and
the uh his video analysis too is film
analysis it's funny you mentioned uh
wearing glasses because he actually
directly references this metaphor
um by comparing it to uh the john
carpenter movie they live yeah that's
where that's what i was thinking about
and the kind of thing that he points out
is
actually you know you don't take off the
glasses of ideology you have to put on
glasses of critical theory precisely to
be able to deconstruct
the world that's presented to us and see
what's really going on beneath it
because our natural predisposition if
you want to call it that is to live
embedded in these kind of ideological
frameworks and it's
the point that victor is making which is
even more radical is that even if we put
the glasses on would we even give a [ __ ]
anyway
yeah exactly that was kind of that's
true because because that's the whole
point of j jack's thing when he says i
know very well that all these things are
happening but yet my behavior doesn't
change
but it's like i have conscious awareness
and like i know whereas like sort of the
the the way i when i was watching pills
video i was thinking okay like the 1990s
like the early 90s late 80s when the
first desert storm happened it's like
these technologies were newer and they
were being controlled and then like the
analysis maybe at the time was like oh
they're controlling it they turn it into
a video game so we don't actually see it
but then the golf war number two we do
see it but nothing changes because like
there's wikileaks because it doesn't
actually matter whether we see it or not
we want to believe that
it's a different kind of question right
because he talks a lot about that with
reference to the ecological crisis right
and the way that he sometimes seems to
explain that away is by saying
when people say you know i know very
well but uh it's because they secretly
don't actually believe uh in the kind of
deconstruction of ideology that they've
undertaken right they know rationally
that the world is going to fall apart
because the ecological crisis but
secretly they don't believe it right and
the same way they know capitalism is
driven by all these kind of
contradictions but their actions
displayed that they don't really believe
it and i think that if we took your
thesis seriously victor um that it would
actually kind of damage this system
because the predisposition is that if we
really do push people far enough
eventually they both will believe and
act on something uh whereas i'm not
entirely convinced of that i think that
sometimes people might really believe
that we're [ __ ] to use this jekyll
term right
and just decide to come completely
apathetic and indifferent on that basis
i'm not sure if that's still an
ideological gesture or if it's just a
retreat into a kind of cultural nihilism
uh that might also be like a
psychological approach but it's
i think it's just like a
i just think that there's not a like
like the correlation between like like
propositional belief in something and
then how we behave is just like
tenuous
and i'd wonder whether it is like a
cultural nihilism
or if you know a reporter getting blown
up is just one more news cycle about
terrible things that people do that have
nothing to do with us and that we can't
change
and that probably all along we knew was
happening
but i don't know that us
knowing
changes really all that much and the
function of the news
to me is to make us need more news i
mean to react passively not to actually
make us do anything or really to change
something it just seems probably argue
that wikileaks did have an impact on
like and like you know um what's his
name the the the whistleblower um julian
assange is the wikileaks
the nsa one
oh um
was it snowden yes no no no no so like
so he kind of showed oh this stuff is
happening like like a lot of stuff that
we
you know like theorize that they're
using the the sort of like intelligence
technology for it actually is happening
and like it had an impact people were
outraged there's lots of pieces written
about it but then ultimately like did
really much change like yeah this never
reflects on obama i think there's like
i don't want to talk out of my ass but
there's some there's a stat
that it's somewhere around 90 of drone
strikes
don't kill the intended target
yeah so either they miss or they kill
like sounds
yeah no it's pretty documented there's
there's loads of cross people cotton
crossfire and misidentification too and
you can talk about the sort of you could
talk about the sort of like ways they
train ai is not as insufficient
right it builds in racism it builds in
kinds of prejudices and things like that
yeah but yeah even un like learning that
like okay from snowden learning that the
government may be listening into your
phone calls our wires are tapped those
sorts of things like it doesn't change
much because we seem to have already
kind of suspected that that's happening
and
whether or not you get proof of that it
it's me like i've
you act in such a way as if it were true
just to err on the side of caution and
then when you learn it is true it's like
oh well okay i guess i'm just justified
to keep doing what i'm doing anyway
maybe be a little more paranoid and a
little more cautious and hopefully don't
grow up a kind of paranoid
psycho psychopathology out of it but but
yeah that's what you just carry on doing
what you're already kind of assuming is
going on in the first place like yeah
atrocities and war are best friends we
know that and whether or not they show
us images that are sort of patriot
washed
and and sort of
you know geared towards a public
relations kind of point of view we
understand what's going on behind that
because that's what it is ideology we
understand that this is not the way it
seems and even that deeper truth that we
know may be just another layer to the
mystery rather than the point we stop at
and say that's the truth i'm going to
act based on that notion because you
know
it keeps evolving
it raises an interesting question that's
kind of partially at the center of a lot
of my research was just like for radical
politics for egalitarian movements
like well i think there's an interesting
relation or there's there's kind of like
interesting inconsistencies about like
how
the relationship between like knowledge
or awareness of stuff or consciousness
of things uh and action like how how
because you know obviously going back to
marx there's this idea that like class
consciousness is like this crucial thing
and and like you know even watching
pills video it's like it seemed like
there's an implication that like oh
they're using these technologies
to to present a washed image because if
we saw the real image of what was
happening right like maybe we wouldn't
we wouldn't uh you know comply with this
with the way the situation is but then
you know but then there's also theory or
there's also like lots of we but now we
know it's almost like a truism about
like
you know we're almost like cynical
about like the assumption that that that
governments hide things that that and
and we've seen images these leaks and
it's like you know seems like like what
is the precipitator of change i guess in
people's behaviors and the way and what
they're willing to accept or not i have
a sort of different take on that i think
that pills is right that the medium
accelerates these kinds of processes of
desensitization and withdrawal from the
reality or the tangibility of violence
but i also think that if you take the
philosophy of war seriously the way that
we conceptualize war has become a lot
more total uh over the course of
probably the last hundred a couple
hundred years and consequently we begin
to be a lot more desensitized to
individual acts of violence because we
don't go to war with individual people
or even armies anymore but with total
societies and the ideologies that we
perceive them as representing i mean if
you think of
the medieval if you think about like the
bible right um corbin mccarthy expresses
this really nicely in blood meridian
right there's this notion that war is
natural in fact more might even be the
natural state of humankind uh and it's
not to be blamed upon anyone it's just
the way things go you go forward to like
the chivalric age there's this kind of
one-on-one notion of war you see with
the aristocracy right that i'm warning
against you
or the knights are warring against other
knights
now we move on to the era where we're
fighting against entire societies and
what they represent and the media plays
a part in
creating the sense of totalization so in
that respect what does it really matter
if somebody dies who might not have been
a combatant they were still a part of
that society ergo they are still an
enemy of some way shape or form or at
least they're embedded in that guilt by
association and can't really extricate
themselves from that well yeah war war
is a natural part of
capitalism and the expansion of
interests and imperialism and finding
new markets but it's the same i think
there's the same argument to be made
that zizek and badil say about like
nature with a capital n right when you
totalize it generalize it naturalize it
in this way and to have war with a
capital w
well from gg's perspective what happens
is it becomes an empty signifier or from
from badu's perspective it becomes
de-politicized it becomes something set
out over and against politics right it
becomes something like an empty
signifier in which it has to remain
empty of all content in order for it to
perform a kind of organizing function on
the chain of signifiers so it itself
cannot have any content so these new
efforts to sort of look at nature or
look at war as things like
socio-technical assemblages is supposed
to offer a more politicizing point of
view one that isn't based on those sorts
of universals so we have the idea of
nature and war as socio-technical
assemblages specific to capitalism with
a contingent history that could be
otherwise yeah if really i talked about
this
no he's saying it
it's saying it
so this
you're talking about total war but total
war is this idea that's already existed
since the 19th century that the whole
economy the whole political apparatus is
all going to mobilize itself together
but verilio brings up this new idea that
he thinks was born in the gulf also
which is pure war
and i want to kick it to matt
yeah absolutely i mean
one of the things that berelia points
out is there was this notion of total
war that emerged in the 19th century
that was really popularized during the
first and the second world war and
involved this notion that we're waging
war against an ideology but the nice
thing about it was you could still
localize that ideology in a specific
place you know nazi germany is nazi
germany we go invade berlin that's the
end of it right uh whereas now with this
notion of pure war we've entered into a
phase where there is no localization to
these ideologies they become global and
they spread themselves out with such
speed and rapidity that there's really
no way of containing them think about
this idea of war against islamic
fundamentalism or islamic
totalitarianism
and a network of terrorism that spreads
across the globe and could be anywhere
you know it could be localized at some
points in afghanistan but it could also
be some guy on your computer
in a suburban neighborhood in the united
states you have no way of knowing right
uh so there's this complete
liquidation of the very notion that
we're waging war against something
physical and specific and a movement
towards war as a kind of pure activity
wage for its own sake against an enemy
that can never be pinned down uh that
we'll always have to confront and it's a
really frightening kind of prospect
right so that's the
sorry i just have to add this because
it's the main definition of pure war is
that this is purified of humans we don't
have to go anywhere we don't have to
send the boys off anywhere and for
virilio this is purely technological
violence and it figures as as technology
with increasingly independence makes war
on us
as humanity there is no peace anymore
there's just perpetual surveillance
perpetual drone striking perpetual
enemies the war on terror is pure war so
pure war is the end point and we don't
know
where like a final tipping point's gonna
happen you know the accident but every
human is a potential
target yeah and the uh the the sort of
technical term in semiotics for that
would be the purification of war is war
becoming a floating signifier that
becomes radically decontextualized and
sort of
mobile and attachable to different
situations investable with different
kinds of psychological and cultural
values so it loses its context and just
kind of floats around over and above
like this empty organizing function
again
yeah i'd also like to just point out
here really quickly that this is very
easy that that like i was correct and uh
and that we could do an episode about
this even though both even though two of
you haven't even watched the video but
but easily i knew we could do a good
episode with that yeah lucky video i
wanted to talk about this book with
litvik and i hope we do an episode on at
some point but cory mccarthy has a great
book called blood meridian that i
referenced before uh where the character
of the judge who stands in for a lot of
things but one of them is the american
modernist attitude has this
extraordinary monologue where he says
war is god and before man was war was
there waiting for him right
and the argument that he makes is that
humankind wants war we were lusting
after it from the very beginning
precisely because it is a kind of pure
engagement a contest in which
everything is put at stake life and
death and so existence is kind of
elevated to its highest pitch and in an
era like modernity and now
post-modernity where precisely these
kinds of affective drives for meaning
become extremely powerful uh the notion
of a kind of endless war would become
extremely appealing because to go back
to benjamin and i'm sure eric knows this
right and
happy with this uh nothing is much more
entertaining than an endless war right
there's nothing that we can libido and
invest ourselves in more than something
like that uh and particularly when we
can dissociate from it and assume that
we can get all the kind of fun and
excitement of war without ever actually
putting ourselves personally at risk uh
which isn't to say that real people
aren't destroyed they are uh it just
happens to be in countries so far away
from us and an area is so distant from
us uh that we don't give a crap normally
places like afghanistan yeah and that's
why i see it formally so similar to the
ecological problem right because it's
like war nature is always treated as
that elsewhere that place that place you
that things go when you flush the toilet
that place that the garbage trucks pick
up your [ __ ] and dump it it's just
other it's just elsewhere it's nowhere
right it doesn't matter i can i can
disengage i can i can go about my day
and not worry about it and in a way to
worry about it too much is a sign of a
kind of psychological disturbance that
we want to sort of
police each other out of that we want to
cure each other of because just you know
just enjoy your life man why worry about
these things going on on the other side
of the world right they're not affecting
you so don't trouble yourself with them
it's a it's a powerful sort of again
ideology yeah i'll convey an anecdote
that kind of brought this home for me um
when i was about 20 years old i went to
go see romeo de lair speak does everyone
here know who romeolaire is shook hands
with the devil
so he was a commander of the un mission
in rwanda right and he tried to save as
many people as it could during uh he's
canadian by the way trying to save as
many people as he could during the
genocide but he was basically told
primarily by the western states to not
intervene because we didn't want to put
used pills to term our boys in harm's
way so we allowed the people to
slaughter each other uh in the hundreds
of thousands uh and to this day he wrote
uh he feels extraordinarily bad about
that uh me being really young didn't
appreciate that because i considered him
kind of a hero for saving the few people
he did and i went up and i congratulated
him saying you know you're real
inspiration to those of us who are
involved in human rights et cetera et
cetera and he looked me in the eyes like
do you really think like
i did something that was all that great
like i saved a couple hundred people
whereas the story of what happened was
hundreds of thousands of people being
eradicated by their neighbors their
brothers their friends you name it and
it was a really shocking kind of moment
for me because i never really thought
about it that before but i think it was
really symptomatic of the fact that i
was embedded
as we all are and exactly the kind of
things you're talking about
i had only encountered the reality of
war through this book seeing this man
and the only thing i cared about was his
experience uh and i completely
dissociated from
the real consequences of what was going
on there which was the mass genocide of
all these people right
yeah
and you never get to the sense of actual
consequences when war becomes a media
event which is the whole point of
bodrios
uh three three essays on it
because
and this is this is a
perfect parallel to me in my mind and i
think this might be getting at what you
are kind of calling the suggestion
victor is that cnn was like
a back wall a backwater news station and
became a national news station as a
result of the gulf war because it's
24 7 you know whenever you turn on cnn
this is going to be on there we're going
to do 24 7
news
and they've continued that model up to
this day but it starts with the
seduction of war which is you know fun
fun to follow along our reporters are
embedded our reporters are wearing
bulletproof vests so oh they they must
be in danger there you go for a little
bit of a signifier there and this
becomes
this this
i don't know what you call i think
beaujolais calls it a simulacral
he says we're simulacral protagonists so
we're involved in this war like this
this matters to us while at the same
time it matters
not at all to us it barely even mattered
to the soldiers that were there most of
whom never even saw con or con combat if
you've
seen that movie uh three kings i think
oh yeah the george bush three kings and
jarhead too
they're just they're basically sitting
around and then the war was over because
they fought for a hundred hours that was
it it was like three days and they just
walked through the army
basically about him like the whole movie
is like him waiting to shoot somebody
and like not ever being able to he's
just sitting around the whole time does
he not even fire a single shot in that
movie
no
so that's like that is so perfect for
this because
we at home
i mean none of us were watching this
obviously but we at home are
invested where our troops
you know you get like the the armchair
generals just like the armchair
quarterbacks planning oh here's what i
would do
and you get you get like just such a
tiny sliver of information but enough
information that you think that you're
involved and enough footage that you
think you're involved and then this just
comes to dominate the entire event where
you're like ah good we won we watched
this thing on on tv for
whatever it was six weeks and this
became like
the
the origin of cnn which is 24 7 news 24
7 participation and they still do
exactly the same thing with politics
today
yeah rick roderick had a joke about that
in his lecture on beau gerard that i
really like i'm not sure this is true
it's apocryphal but apparently when he
was asked if he wanted to cover the gulf
war beaujoire said he would cover the
gulf war but he wanted to watch it on
cnn because that's where the war was
really going to take place right
i'm not sure if that's true but it
sounds like something butcher i would do
right but you know just the striking
opening of that essay where it says you
know war is real if anything is really
has this kind of cormac mccarthy and
almost biblical quality to it you know
it is real if anything is uh and then
the fact that they can now transform
world into a spectacle just testifies to
how liquid our concept of reality is
right now right which is why i think a
lot of people
kind of misunderstand that essay because
he's not trying to say that this was all
unimportant or not nothing of
significant happened or that
everything's been vandalized even though
it is uh he's describing a kind of
ethical transition in human history
where what was once the most
primal thing that we engaged in uh has
been transformed into pastiche right and
that's and it's [ __ ] correct here
rick roderick wasn't wasn't his claim
that the iraq or the the american
soldiers in iraq were watching the war
on cnn because they weren't even
fighting
oh that's another joke in nietzsche yeah
where he says you know he talked to one
of the janitors at duke who was like
there and he was like so what did you do
there he's like well i more or less did
what i did here you know i was cleaning
up and then they told me one day that it
was over and i was done
um
okay so beaujord has a i don't know why
rick roderick didn't use this example
but this is great
uh beaujolais says that when the
when the offensive actually started like
when the tanks started rolling
um
a huge portion of the iraqi army was
conscripts they didn't even want to be
there or know what they were doing there
um so they were just surrendering left
and right
and
bodriard says the
they were all i don't know i don't know
what his source was but he's like all
the soldiers were trying to surrender to
the cnn cameras they would run past the
soldiers so that they could surrender to
the camera
and he's saying this of course i mean
probably
it probably happened because they were
worried about like getting shot in a
trench like off camera but if you
surrender in front of the camera then
that you know you're safe but this also
shows for baudrillard the camera is the
real power here it's not the tanks it's
not the soldiers you have to
put your or show your surrender on tv
for you to be safe but that demonstrates
who's in power here
yeah and that that reminds me of the way
that when you're at like a protest and
like it you'll people will whip out
their phones when when situations start
to get hairy because the image has that
that reality power it has that reality
value i don't see how else you could
explain something like that without this
concept of hyper reality because then
you have this sort of collapse of the
sort of
old distinction between the image and
the reality right there's the appearance
there on the screen and the reality is
somewhere out there if you're if you're
bringing that kind of
thinking to
to your thinking about war right you're
going to have i guess you're not going
to be considering the hyper real quality
of the war which is the image is the
reality the image is more important and
it has real power it has real power to
change things in the world just like
when at a protest or surrendering in
front of a camera or getting more eyes
on the situation has power in itself and
it's hyper real no but i think that's
what's really problematic is sorry go
ahead victor like well i always wonder
you know when we're thinking about like
hyper reality and like the way the
medium has changed
our kind of like relationship to
knowledge to reality to truth
you know like before you know before cnn
before this like what was it like like
what was the kind of relationship that
regular citizens would have had to
reality and i guess like i'm just kind
of thinking off the top of my head it's
like you know i don't know in napoleon's
time like the french people would have
like heard stories it would have been
what would did they have newspapers back
then like how was reality constructed
for for them and was it any more real uh
was it any more constructed i mean maybe
it was maybe it was like propagandistic
in a kind of different way and like it
would get framed because there was
actually like less access to like
immediate images it would just be like
you know tales of the heroism that would
go on and maybe you actually wouldn't
get as much of like the banal truth that
actually a lot of the time these
soldiers were just like sitting around
like not doing much or or certain
atrocities were
were being so i don't know like how like
i agree that there's something distinct
about like this new medium that does
create this kind of like hyper reality
and i think that's like an interesting
and like kind of like convincing way of
framing things but but like was the was
before hyper reality was it any more
real i guess it's kind of like my
question like in what way i think that's
based on the slowness
there's two images basically that
stopped the vietnam war now i'm not sure
if this is true but this is kind of the
story as we see it in hindsight
the one is that girl running away from
her village
agent orange vision
yeah and the other is uh there's like a
shot of a guy
shooting
a
prisoner like a guy who's like
a handcuffed like a viet cong
shooting him in eow
and this gave so much fuel to the
anti-war movement and anti-war protests
that basically
and then like all the conflicts that
happened on on campuses and in cities in
the united states that made this war so
unpopular that you know the next
president is just going to be whoever
says we're going to we're going to stop
being here
and i think this is the kind of a
narrative i tried to present in this
video is that if if they learned from
that
they learned
oh as long as we control the images as
long as we're the ones that are giving
out the images we don't have
they're not because these are not real
embedded reporters in the gulf war
they're like with a press corps
so they're not getting actually shot at
they're not on the front lines but
they're like
taken along for the ride whereas in
vietnam
there were a few reporters that were
like i'm just gonna go exactly where the
action is i'm gonna follow the soldiers
and i might die for it
so they have this there's this now
contrast where they're creating a hyper
real
complex of images that has nothing to do
with what's actually happening
yeah so that's a difference because what
you were saying what was it like before
if if it's true i'm again i'm not sure
if it's true i wasn't alive but if it's
true that those two images ended the
vietnam war
then they were not going to let any of
those images get out a second time
i want to point out that you're
absolutely correct
in the assumption that this is done
self-consciously
one of the things that people criticized
my post-modern conservatism book for was
not talking enough about the bush
administration uh which my new book on
cosmopolitanism actually does talk about
but in 2004 our new york times reporter
uh interviewed karl rove and carl rove
had this very infamous statement where
he said
you people in the reality-based
community sit there and talk about facts
and whether what we say is true or not
we're an empire now and we create our
own reality and all of you are going to
be doing nothing but sitting there and
interpreting what we do centuries later
right
and he was very cognizant of the fact
that you can exploit imperial power
to direct the construction
of how people conceptualize what it is
that you're doing in this very very
exacting way which he thought he could
achieve with the iraq war right
so i think it's really a mistake to
assume that
leftists are the and i know there's some
leftists who think that we're the ones
are cognizant of this many many many
conservatives are very sensitive to the
way that you can manipulate people using
these kind of hyper-real technologies
and in some ways i would actually argue
they're better at it because
conservatives have always had a very
instinctive understanding of the
capacity of power and individuals who
really will power to remake the world
and in particular to manipulate the
masses to achieve the ends that they
want
and that's something i think on the left
we're instinctively concerned to
criticize
oh yeah i mean the priests and the
pundits and politicians of capitalism
probably know this better than the
leftists do is that the image has that
power right because what was asked
before is what would be the difference
with the old sort of newspaper style of
reality and that's the gap between the
event and the reporting right but today
we have
events occurring that are immediately
disintegrated into a million images all
over the world right so you get the
relationship flips around no longer are
we trying to write the article and fit
the image to the happening but the image
itself is the happening the gap is
closed i think benjamin even makes this
point in his work of art essay is that
more and more now reality is becoming
produced i mean he would talk about like
like like film and and television is
being produced to be reproduced right
and what else is reproduced more than
the image right reality is being
tailored specifically to the way it's
consumed in in modern sort of media mass
media society
and if we ever you know reach some kind
of post-media phase then there'll be a
new there'll be a new chapter in that
theory but for now you know we have an
image administered reality rather than
reality administering the images and
this is why i suspect you know beaudry
art would probably like uh inception
better than better than the matrix
because the matrix holds on to that
reality appearance distinction whereas
inception doesn't right the top is still
spinning at the end so we never really
know if we're all the way out or not we
just go in and out of the layers and
there's no floor there's no ceiling
i did want to i didn't want to like
respond earlier to like i guess the
distinction between like the way that
like the access that journalists had in
vietnam and the vietnam war versus like
i mean i think part of the i mean
especially the second iraq war
there's just like less happening too
right i mean i mean like so because like
the journalists like they did get stuff
out i mean at the very beginning i
brought up the fact like the wikileaks
and like those videos of of like
helicopters like you know destroying
people with these high caliber guns like
into into body parts and stuff like that
and it's like you know that didn't
change anything it's like you know we
saw that obviously if like we saw images
of women and children maybe being being
maimed on like that thing and like and
it was clear that like children's body
parts were getting torn apart i'll bet
that would have made a difference in
people's psyches for sure um it probably
has to do with like the definition of
the video too it's too grainy part of it
that's true that's true that that's
that's so that certainly like makes
makes a difference but i also think like
there's also just like less happening so
it's true that like the image was more
catered but it's also true that like i
mean they weren't dropping napalm right
they weren't like doing any of these
things that were i mean they were doing
these
these drone strikes that don't like i
guess lead drone strikes and like like
you know so-called precision missile
attacks which just don't lend themselves
i guess to the possibility for as many
images of horror just because of the way
that the the weapon functions right so
like it's possible maybe
like compared to at least napalm right
where it's like you know this burning
liquid that's being dropped on villages
[ __ ] it's just like it just lends itself
to the possibility of certain kinds of
images uh being coming out well i want
to say though i think this is a
testament to the fact that we be didn't
become desensitized in the ways that
pills is talking about uh because
something like that did happen and i
remember because i was involved in it
very tentatively so i was part of
amnesty international in high school and
in 2004
april ish or something uh the abagrave
torture videos came out uh sorry photos
came up and there was huge condemnation
of these right and there was this claim
that how can we claim to be any
different when we went in there to blow
saddam up and prevent him from torturing
people and now we're torturing them
again in the same prison we've just
added islamophobia into the mix uh you
know for good measure right uh and far
from having an impact on the american
public bush was re-elected by a bigger
margin uh than he had won in the first
place right
and i think he could chalk some of that
up to fear and animosity in the war on
terror and the fact that 911 wasn't that
long ago but if that photo would come
out um
say two or decades earlier earlier i
think it would have had a much much
bigger impact because i'll tell you like
as much as i pushed that photograph into
everyone's face i could being like look
at the horrible things he's done you
know we need to do something about it
most people's response was a big like eh
what are you gonna do we all know that
everyone's full of [ __ ] the bush of
information full of [ __ ] who cares
anymore right uh and it's really hard to
fight against that kind of destruction
and victor i would like to say in the
gulf war you know that portion that was
uh the man crying in that video
that actually took place after the
america bombing which was a shelter and
it was mostly women and children and
there are images of them cleaning up
with mops
they're just pushing blood
and this is mostly women and children
who are hiding in here and who got
targeted by a quote-unquote precision
missile strike
and even and and that wasn't even
like that wasn't secret i'm sure cnn
didn't report on it i watched a lot of
cnn footage i didn't see
any cnn reporting on it but 400 people
just get eviscerated
and i i just think that we're too
mediatized
to even
get feeling get emotion
i i don't think that we can even think
what people did in the 60s when it comes
to images
yeah i mean i need to be more like the
girls
it's interesting that you because what i
was about to say i was actually like i
cut the one thought i had is like i i
think that there's definitely something
this idea that we've been like
desensitized mediatized or whatever
but but i also like i'm thinking about
like the impact of that image right like
the vietnam war image
of that uh you know that woman naked
woman screaming running from like the
flaming village or whatever if i'm even
remembering it's possible i'm
misremembering that yeah
yeah okay a little little girl yeah and
so but but
but but then i also think it's like okay
well have there been any images that
created like a [ __ ] storm in modern
memory and then i thought about the
image of that little boy's body washing
up yeah
right and and it's like and i also
wonder which one is there
it was from
the civil war during the refugee crisis
the refugee crisis and like they were
trying to get to like maybe italy they
were trying to cross across the
mediterranean sea
and then like so this means that that
was nothing sad though that was [ __ ]
i look at that that's my point but
that's my point is like maybe there's
actually something in our psyche so like
i do think we've been mediatized but i
think also like the type of image like
the specificity of it it's like maybe
seeing body parts of women and children
isn't quite enough like it needs to be
something
that like is like a child and like it
somehow evokes a kind of suffering for
it to like have an effect on us or like
enough people because i think like maybe
there's something i guess what i'm sort
of like off the cuff hypothesizing is
maybe there's something that that image
of the boy washing up on shore and like
girl running in vietnam have something
in common that these other images that
we've seen just don't and i don't know
and like part of it might be about the
mediatization
of us but i mean part of it might just
be that there's like there's just
specific kinds of images that will hit
the right kind of nerve that will
actually get
um which which speaks to like i guess
our human kind of vulnerabilities and
like our inability to
make connections between or like
turn images into or if images seem to
abstract us like empathize with it but
you can
could you see the boy's face in that
photograph that you're talking about
i think but you can flip that
you can flip that whole thing over
and say like okay so how do we be
proactive about these things though
because if we if images are what do this
to us then images keep us reactive they
keep us paralyzed they keep us waiting
for the next big thing to happen and you
can't be proactive because you need the
image in order to do something about any
situation
so it's it's almost like a form of
paralysis as well
because you have these grotesque images
emerging from war
and then you have this sort of reactive
cons like you're consuming the image you
react to the image there's a short burst
of outrage
and it's like very well i guess it's
very well documented and studied by now
is that the images themselves but it
does speak to the power of images still
in this ridiculous ongoing persecution
of julian assange that the biden
administration has just
chosen to completely continue on with is
that instead of
attacking the content of the images
what's really going on what did chelsea
manning show us with this leak that
julian assange helped get out no it's
not addressing the issues it's
addressing the image right stop the leak
it's couched in the terms of whatever
national security it's couched in terms
of of
of you know journalism versus espionage
and sensitive secrets
sensitive information and whatever
that's all an excuse to attack not even
like attack the messenger basically not
even the messenger the the medium attack
the medium itself rather than the
reality that is
purported to be revealed to us through
these images and so i mean they know
very well these are
incorporated into the political
strategies that go on and julian
assange's continued persecution is
ridiculous but proof of that i think
yeah and i want to testify that i think
that
you're right first off that these things
can't be manipulated because if you look
at the kind of visual reactions that
have occurred as a result of these
images most of them have been very
transient haven't affected broad change
and in fact it's been the political
right that's been better able to harness
the power of imagery in order to create
permanent and enduring political
movements committed to the advancement
of their causes take the example uh of
the kid who was drowned as part of the
refugee crisis right uh there is a
momentary moment by the way if anybody
wants to look that up
you can just uh google the death of alan
kurdi k-u-r-d-i
yeah it's haunting stuff especially when
you consider that syria was a fractured
nation uh left alone because of european
colonialism and we bear a lot of the
blame for what happened there decades
later right
but the primary movement that was
mobilized as a result of the european uh
refugee crisis
wasn't the political left
and humanitarian causes it was a
political right which surged to power in
many countries
because they were able to better
mobilize images of so-called hordes of
refugees entering your country looking
dangerous and we need to do something
about that and that's true in hungary
it's true in poland it's true in germany
it was true in the uk and was a big
factor with the brexit vote if you think
back to nigel farage right or you could
flash forward to i think was 2018
when there was the crisis going on in
the u.s border where i remember times
tried to make exactly that parallel when
they pointed to some of the children who
were in cages being engaged by um the
trump administration and they said
directly this is our vietnam image right
this is going to finally be the point
where people break away from trump
because this is just beyond the pale
a week later no one gave a [ __ ] no one
cared at all yeah right it's too
short-lived and now even under biden
right there they're he just approved the
building of like a private prison for
for ice prisoners specifically or
something like that like
yeah just people
yeah
yeah
and the only people who benefited from
that were trump trump gained
weeks and weeks of traction from his
supporters all of them said invading
caravan invading cameraman must do what
we want i saw somebody who went on i
think was fox news and when he's shown a
picture of the children in cages his
response was
did not care and he was cheered on by
their ace right-wing media right
so we're really very bad i think at
finding ways to take the initial spur of
humanitarianism that's generated from
these extraordinarily haunting images
and transforming them into the kind of
lasting political movements as eric
would put it that will really affect
change uh the ones who are good at doing
that are the political right call them
post-modern conservatisms or fascists or
whatever you want right so i think we
need to be a lot better at it i'm not
sure what the solution is i think we'd
be re i think we'd be remiss if we
didn't bring up at this point because
the reason i asked were they body parts
or how do they have faces which sounds
extremely callous
but emmanuel lebanos
the
face of the other and he's not talking
about necessarily physical faces
but the sort of metaphysical
experience of
a face
not really a physical face maybe we have
to do a whole episode on this
but
the experience of seeing someone else
there
is part of that
um i don't know that call to
a deep humanity
might be a good way to say it that you
realize that this is another person and
for whatever reason this kid on the
beach picture did that
and this uh
kid in the cage didn't do that
yeah for a brief period of time i should
say very brief
yeah i mean you get the same thing with
the with uh stanley kavel too and the
importance of the face right you get
like that shot of that old school movie
with joan of arc
and then you have the sort of opposite
conversation about pornography which
which completely sort of dis
disintegrates the body into parts and
erogenous zones and there's no unity to
it the only unity you get in pornography
is when someone gets out and makes a
makes a expose or a documentary but
that's not you know that's not how it
works that's not what's oh it's
libidinally exciting about pornography
even though it's a terrible industry we
know that it's got so much horrible [ __ ]
going on it's that
those body parts and those signifiers
and those at that sort of disunity that
gets you so i don't know if that that
idea that can then be flipped into uh
you know if you see body parts from a
war it's it's it doesn't have enough
unity for us to want to do something
that's just that's just a hand that's
just a purloined fist or something like
that who knows well i just want to end
with this then i have to go because i
got to make dinner for the next three
days uh but i think one of the
interesting things about what we've been
talking about how many days what are you
talking about what are you making
don't you want to know
because the kind of hyper-saturation of
images and how counter-intuitive
this development might seem uh looking
backwards because think of alfiko's
discipline and punish right he says that
the transition from societies of
sovereignty where violence was deployed
as a spectacular means of control
to disciplinary societies in one sense
uh was the attempt to hide violence hide
the reality of state coercion right so
rather than executing someone in public
we did it behind closed doors because we
felt a certain sense of guilt and
humanitarianism about it
and i think what we see now kind of
confirming to lose a society of control
thesis along with the notch of others as
how people have recognized that trying
to hide the reality of violence doesn't
necessarily work because it can come out
in precisely the kind of vietnam way
that pills was talking about so the
other solution is to just super saturate
everyone with these kinds of images so
they become completely desensitized to
the reality of what's going on and they
can never have enough time to actually
assemble the kind of critical energies
that would be necessary to mobilize
against any of the developments that
they're witnessing right that's nice
can i give an example of that i mean
it's in my it's in my video if you want
to watch it but i am going to watch it
tomorrow but
the guy that he's a colonel in the air
force or something and he's like showing
the reporters what's happening
and it's a an f-115
dropping a bomb on a building
and he's like this is my he makes a joke
about it he's like this is my uh
my
basically my equivalent in the air force
here this is like the air force building
in iraq and we're dropping a bomb on it
and they all laugh and they're all just
sitting there
watching a bomb drop on this building
like do you think that building's empty
yeah
it's just
this is that this is the headquarters of
my iraqi counterpart oh yeah my
counterpart and they and they're all
laughing and i'm like is this not insane
that we're just like
watching people die
and laughing about it like this is like
an entertain this is just entertainment
they might as well be sitting in a
[ __ ] movie theater watching avengers
11. yeah and as a testament to the kind
of phenomenological point about the face
that you're mentioning one of the things
that foco points out in that book that i
think is really brilliant is that the
problem with these kind of sovereign
displays of violence is that when people
go and watch someone get executed they
start to empathize with the person being
who's suffering right rather than seeing
him as a traitor to the crown they say
why is the crown doing all this kind of
horrible stuff to him look at his face
look at how much pain he's in we should
do something about it which is one of
the motivations to move towards display
powers and hide it away
whereas now
you could see a lot of people who are
involved in exactly the same kind of
suffering uh being inflicted upon them
as what happened in uh earlier forms of
sovereign power but because there's so
many of them and because we see them on
screens we become desensitized to it and
we look at a building blowing up like
pills said and we say look at that you
know it's kind of like what i did in
call of duty i remember i blew up a
building in some weird middle eastern
country that was awesome you know
it's really just a shocking kind of
development and it makes me very worried
for the future
but this is before call of duty even
this is like the old
the origin of call of duty is cnn
the purpose of call of duty is that you
get to do that cool [ __ ] that you saw on
tv
yeah i mean i get that sense what you're
saying just when you started matt gave
me
made me think of of the ways that you
know the right-wing media machine is
kind of caught up with the left-wing
kind of image administered reality point
of view
because they know that for every
narrative you can just put out a counter
narrative immediately for every image
there's a counter image for every way of
understanding some event there's some
alternative way of understanding it it
creates a kind of radical uncertainty
in people and i think i mean
not to transition to anything else but i
think that's where cancel culture tends
to get its strength from is that we no
longer trust the image we have to go
with our gut we have to stick to our
principles we need things we need some
kind of guide to
sussing out the meaning
among all of this mess of images and
counterpoints and points
and it energizes it in a certain way
because all we have left to cling to are
our morals and if we slide into nihilism
then there's no meaning and it is just
nothing but it becomes a political
strategy on the right to do that every
time we put out something about how war
is bad they'll put out something about
how war is good i read this image this
way oh my god there's right on the right
on 4chan or some [ __ ] place like that
there's another way of reading the image
that also
gets defenders
right so how do you ever like consensus
in our culture is
probably the furthest thing away from
reality at all because we can't agree
about anything
yeah i agree uh but i i will say i gotta
go but i think it's a really neat
conversation and i'll see you all when
we i get back okay
see ya
bye
all right well
yeah that was off the cuff
all right so matt had to leave um just
so you you patrons know
we had a completely different topic
planned and then it turned into hyper
reality and war
yeah which is a good topic it felt
organic and we gotta cling to that when
we can but i i am a little disappointed
i did spend a good amount of time
prepping and making a little crib sheet
today
so we'll still do that one we'll still
do that one next time okay cool yeah we
were well just just as a preview i guess
though we're going to talk about the
chair which is a show on netflix so i
guess if you hear this then and you
haven't seen that yet then check it out
you might not enjoy it you might you
might watch some of it to get an idea of
how it is
it's only three hours but before the
next two weeks we're gonna talk about
the chair because it's a show about
academia cancel culture tenureship
campus protesting hysterical hysterical
students right so we're gonna and it
actually does quite a good even-handed
job of dealing with some of these issues
but we we we've all been a university
some of us still are as narcissists we
love when people talk about us in on
netflix yeah anything i feel like i have
anything i feel like i have first-hand
experience that i got to jump on the
opportunity to talk about it because
everything else is
everything else i've seen in images only
and i don't know if it's real
yeah for sure
anyway did you have any follow-ups on
this uh
image
versus reality
notion because this is like
i mean it's beaujord's entire thesis but
i i think this word desensitization
it's a little bit off in some way
because and i and i don't know what i
mean but like we we hear
people that have always talked about or
you're gonna get desensitized if you
play like too much counter strike then
you're not gonna grand theft auto was
the big one right it's gonna desensitize
you to violence to thievery and there's
something off about that word but
there's also something about like if you
see one other image in a day even if
it's a terrible image
it's it doesn't have the same gravity so
i see what that word is saying but i
also don't see the connection between
playing too much gta and then you're
actually going to like just beat
somebody up well i think the studies
have shown that there is no connection
there and i think it's we are right to
distrust that word because the context
it always comes up in is finding
something to blame for moral failures or
criminality or something what are we
gonna blame in this decade it's gonna
last decade was grand theft auto what do
we blame now social media right or
something or a universe before that it
was satanism and heavy metal yeah every
every [ __ ] generation has its big
scapegoats for its problems and they
tried to shoehorn video games into that
but now we know things like video games
actually have great benefits if you play
a lot play a lot of video games and you
you're a better pilot you're a better
driver they want people who play video
games in the army in certain capacities
yeah yeah and i also i was going to say
like isn't it in a way more accurate
like especially if we think about it
from a sort of phenomenological lens to
say that like images or like kind of the
uh being saturated in certain kinds of
images or i mean in the case of video
games i guess that's more than images
too that's like activity that you're
doing with your body
it's actually like not desensitizing but
it's actually just creating a different
kind of sensitivity matrix or something
like that it's it's like you're you know
your your your presuppositions
you're the way like your pre-reflective
engagement with the world is altered by
it so you actually like your body
becomes sensitive just in a different
way so like it just takes up maybe part
of that is is that is like this effect
where it becomes hyper real in the sense
that like
it it it doesn't have the impact that it
maybe would have had but that's not
because you're less sensitive but just
because it's like becomes part of like
the background uh and it's taken up and
it's mediated through screen too which
already
uh doesn't doesn't feel uh like real in
the same sense yeah i like that
i like that i like william and i like
raymond williams term um every every
sort of era has its own unique structure
of feeling and and
and video games
contribute big to altering our our
structure of feeling right i can
my my reality is permeated with video
games i've played them since i was a kid
and and i don't know sometimes i walk
down the street and go do do do do do do
do do do do or like hum some super mario
or something like that i don't know it's
just and yeah you do get different
sensitivities right even like you know
the the click of the clicking of a
shotgun make you think of the game doom
or something like that rather than uh
something people might someone else
might think of i don't know a lynch mob
or something like that who knows someone
might put think bird shot buckshot bird
shot buckshot when you hear that i don't
know it creates a different sensitivity
exactly exactly actually just like a
super like you know kind of benign
example this morning i watched this
video it's like a new vox video and it
was about how like the sound of a loon a
loon call
how it's like used ubiquitously in
movies
whenever there's like a nature scene and
how it drives like bird watchers crazy
because it's just like it's just used
because and i realized that like they
showed a bunch of scenes
and for some reason the loon call just
like has become associated with
like
the wilds nature so it doesn't matter
like where it is loons only exist in
canada and like the northern united
states
but for some reason you'll see like
movies sometimes even on different
planets
and it'll be like
a loon noise in the background yeah talk
about a floating signifier eh yeah and
then when i hear it all i think of those
shitty national heritage commercials we
used to be exposed to all the time
or or or the commercials
is it just a
and i'm asking also the the patrons
because you have the ability to comment
here um but if that's not the word
i i think we're all agreeing that
there's something to that
like if you if you see
one other image after you've seen 10 000
images that day which we typically do
then what is it about desensitization
and then why is it that every once in a
while one of these images actually
breaks through
and maybe one possible
response to this could be you know
mcluhan's dictum
the medium is the message so if you get
your image through news
the message of news
is that there's always more news that's
what news is it's like you know do your
reaction
and then move on because there's
something else coming right down the
pike so get ready so
that would that would be a contrary
thesis to desensitization it would be
like okay i'm done with that information
i have to get ready for whatever's
coming next so i can't really
spend too much time getting outraged and
becoming an activist over this one issue
because there's more news coming
yeah i think we were on something when
we were talking about the face i think
the face i mean loving us you know
bringing in lebanon's like i think that
makes sense i think the face does have
an impact i mean that picture of the boy
on the beach you can't actually see his
full face but you can see
most of it you see enough of it that
you're like oh wow that's a little boy
jesus christ like does anyone want to
give the brief summary of the faciality
i i don't know i don't know it well
enough to just summarize it damn i
haven't i haven't read it in years but
if i can if i can try
you see the face as like the forward
face of the other
and the other
is something that you know is like real
and deep
that the face is only in front of
so you know that there's more reality
there you know that there's like a we
would just say in normal language we'd
say there's a person there i'm
empathetic towards them i
i feel like they feel the same way that
i feel about things and the face is like
just the surface of that so it's uh this
like
radical empathy
that you can get and we're talking about
it in terms of the image here which i
think is not it's not misplaced
but there's something about seeing
and maybe that's the difference between
that that that apache helicopter
gunning down a reporter why that
wouldn't have the same effect as
maybe the uh
the those prison photos the abu ghraib
photos or the or the vietnam ones yeah i
mean just to even just to add to that
because i can't summarize it better than
that but you know levynos believes that
ethics was the fundamental philosophy
rather than ontology so this is a kind
of story of the origin of our like
ethical selves and our ethical being so
you have you know you're supposed to
take this figuratively and not
historically but back in like when you
say like a tribe right they'd never seen
outsiders everybody's face they i did
they kind of directly identify with
their own face but then you see the face
of the other you know they come the face
suddenly pops through the bushes and
then you you pause right you're going to
stab that thing and then you pause and
see that it has a face and that's
supposed to be a kind of story of like
the metaphysical origins of ethics and
why it's the first philosophy and i
don't really know how to shoehorn god
into that because he has the the self
the other and the third which is like
kind of like a god the infinite
perspective kind of thing and and that
that beginning leads you towards the say
sort of infinity and god and all those
other sorts of big ethical categories he
he he writes about in his books like
what totality and infinity the basis of
it is i
see you
i don't know you
but i still don't want to kill you
that's like the first experience because
otherwise it is
if you have to pause and think is this
is an enemy is it a friend is it oh no
it's something like me
and that's the beginning of
philosophy
and patrons i do want you to take that
with a grain of salt because like i said
it's been here since i read it but we're
we're not wrong we're in the right
ballpark the face is the face of the
other yeah that's pretty good and then
this this question of desensitization
yeah i think just my my last cent on
that is just it's it's a misnomer right
because it's supposed to be our moral
sensitivity and not our like actual
sensitivity although it does have those
you know those connotations of of skin
and feel raw skin right and then
scabbing over and it becomes
desensitized but like it'll very
literally whereas i think anesthetized
is probably better i like drawing that
from benjamin as well when you're
anesthetized you're made passive you're
made into an object of politics rather
than an active participant in it
and so
anesthetics is the sort of
aesthetic of fascism whereas aesthetics
becoming awakened is kind of the
aesthetics of communism and that's the
one we want to go for we want to go for
the the
aesthetics which is again is the greek
word for your senses right if you take
it back to its origins it actually just
refers to kind of your your perceptual
apparatus and the sort of
what we were talking about earlier the
structure of our perceptual apparatus
our structure of feeling or our per our
sense of different sensitivities
so we want to cultivate that in our sort
of
image-based worlds and so
desensitization seems to have these
weird moralistic overtones that i don't
like and i think it's a misnomer as a
result of that too
yeah i agree with that
so that was good that was a pretty nice
little uh
yeah
um
just so the patrons know before we
started talking
victor was like oh we should do a an
episode on that video i'm like nah no
one's gonna have no one's gonna have
anything to say about that so victor i
have to publicly apologize to you for
second guessing yeah yeah you were wrong
and just to be clear too it also started
with with you being like okay well why
don't you just like talk for five
minutes about like what you thought
about the video and then we'll
transition and then we're like we start
talking like 15 minutes in pills is just
like in the chat yeah maybe we should
just keep talking just keep going
like
let's look for a transition i don't know
how we're going to pull council culture
out of war and hyper reality but we
could we could probably do it but it was
i think it was probably better this way
you know an episode's an episode my prep
work can still be preserved
and uh it's always good to also just do
the cross platform because like even
though we don't have anything to do with
videos i still think it's nice to have
the like uh
to like have some cross-pollination of
talking about videos and on the podcast
yeah that's good stuff we we should we
should do this from time to time so if
you're if you're listening to this uh we
do have a lot of stuff prepared for the
chair
which is not like it's definitely not
the best show ever made or anything like
that it's just uh it connects to our
experience and it's really
incisive on on many points on what it
does and it's only it's only like what
three hours total yeah yeah there's
short little episodes like they're i
think they're like under half an hour
most of the episodes like there's
something that you can just like take
little bite-sized pieces of as you go
watch an episode here and there
yeah they're funny and i i do think it
is it is a very sophisticated kind of
treatment of cancer culture and
tenureship and intergenerational
struggles so that will be i think
was really good yeah they cast it pretty
well i think they cast it very well and
sandra oh she's a ottawa native from my
hometown yeah of grey's anatomy and um
what's that other show she was in
killing eve
of that fame
i really like the big names the old
[ __ ] lady yeah she's awesome she was i
know i know a professor exactly like her
one time oh yeah
i wonder if it's the same one that's uh
sarah paulson's wife i believe uh sarah
paulson's uh big character in american
horror story that's her wife yeah she's
very funny and a good actor
anyways patrons um we're gonna give you
the choice of an episode coming up we're
also working on a big series which we're
excited about don't wanna
don't wanna jump the gun here but uh
thank you
for your support what'd you say
i just said don't anticipate too many
things because they get to choose an
episode they got the chair thing coming
up that's enough yeah but they wanna
yeah they gotta pick one for us
we haven't done that since like
may so
got some stuff in the pipelines just
don't pick just don't pick to lose okay
thanks
everyone going to do it now you just
sealed the deal
i know i know
all right reading about their take on
faciality now that's all they're going
to want to hear what is that what do
they say about it you're going to have
to open up a big copy of atp and start
fuzz fussing with what's going on
well the problem is like that there's
almost probably more written on that
plateau than any of the other plateaus
so it would it would be a bit of
unpacking we'd be beating a dead horse
mostly it's a good concept it's been
done
anyway thank you all very much
and uh we'll see you next week
add you indeed
talk to you next week i shouldn't say
that yeah
thank you
[Music]